and what i want to do is i want to push
on this a little further because
essentially what we did to get to these
answers
was we used the rectangular form of a
complex number i mean that's
it's written in rectangular form right x
plus iy
these are not the only tools that we
have access to right so i want us to
make a little subheading and we're going
to use our other two forms
of complex numbers we already know what
the answers are going to be but i think
you're going to yield
it's going to yield some insight we've
seen this before right the more
different perspectives
more different perspectives the more
perspective you look at something from
the more insight you gain
so we're going to use polar very very
briefly
and exponential form
to find the same roots but try and gain
some new insight okay we're going to
begin at the same spot
omega cubed equals one okay now
as promised i'm going to go first to
polar form that's where i'm going to go
first
this is a complex number that i can
write in polar form it's written in
rectangular form right now
there's the real part there's no
imaginary part
how would i rewrite one unity
in polar form not a trick question
okay it's gonna start with the cos right
because we've got the cos we've got the
i sign part
you've already implied um because of you
where you know this is
you've already applied a modulus here
haven't you right polar forms needs a
modulus
and an argument what's the modulus
you're implying one
so now i just need an argument what is
the argument of one
yeah it's an angle of zero because i'm
measuring from the positive real axis
and i'm already there so it's an angle
of zero so cos of zero
plus i sine of zero
so far so good okay now this is the way
we would say one
with a principal argument this is the
smallest angle you can use
to define where this is but we know the
principal argument is not the only
argument there are many others
infinitely many and so i just want to
remind you that cos and sign
are periodic functions they repeat every
how often
2 pi radians right so cos 0 plus i sine
0
isn't that the same as i'll fit it here
cos
2 pi plus i sine 2 pi
do you agree with that and i could i
could keep going as long as i want right
i could go to the next one
go another 2 pi radians around it
because 4 pi plus
i sine of 4 pi and so on
now i'm pausing there not just because
i've run out of space on my whiteboard
but in fact
the particular number of solutions i
have on the board is important to me
if your wheels are turning you can have
a think about why we'll return to this
fact remind me if i don't remember
but now what i'm going to do that's all
i'm going to do in polar form i just
wanted to remind ourselves
that in polar form we've got this
periodicity that we can express the same
number in different ways
now i'm going to rewrite this in
exponential form because it's
easier and lazier right our exponential
form just to remind you
looks like this r e to the i theta
same pieces right modulus argument what
did we say the modulus was
one so this first one here is just e
like there's no
there's no extra number out the front i
don't need to write one e to the i
zero there's the first one okay i can
rewrite this one as well it's going to
be
e to the i 2 pi new angle
and then the last one i have on my row
is e to the i
4 pi okay dot dot
now why might it be useful for me to do
this well
i'm trying to deal with this sorry it's
a very messy three
i'm trying to deal with this power right
exponential form is presented in such a
way
as to make dealing with powers very easy
right
i don't want w cubed i just want sorry w
even i did it
i don't want omega cubed i want just
omega
so what should be the operation that we
apply to both sides
i think in terms of powers here that
will give me not a mega cube but just
omega what power should i raise to
let's go it should be a third right
because if i raise this
let's write it if i raise omega cubed
to the power of a third by index laws
three times a third just gives me one
this will just be omega right
well you can't just do it to the
left-hand side you've got to do it to
the right-hand side so let's let's do
all of them right
um i'm gonna have i times zero that will
be divided by three
multiplication by third then the next
one along
sorry that's messy on three and then
this is the last one that i had in my
list
also divided by three okay that's a very
subtle difference right but
i want to clarify what's going on in
here yeah
this i to the 0 and 3 is really still
i sorry e to the i 0 because 0 divided
by 3
still 0 right this i'm going to write as
e
to the i and i'm just going to isolate
that angle in there because that's
the way we write it in exponential form
not the whole thing divided by some
number
but i just want that angle divided by
that so that's i
times two pi on three are you okay with
that last one along
four pi on three dot dot dot
okay now hopefully this matches up to
what we saw before right we already you
already told me this is two pi on three
it's four pi on three though a bit pesky
right it's the long way around clearly
it's going
anti-clockwise but there was a shorter
way to get there right what's the
shorter path
yeah just go go clockwise instead of
anti-clockwise so what i would do is i
would say
this guy is just one i already knew what
that was this guy's already written
in the correct form principle argument
and everything and then lastly here i'm
going to write this as e to the i
not positive 4 pi 3. that's
anti-clockwise i'm going to write it as
negative 2 pi on 3 because that's
coming around the other way can you see
that is that all right
now hopefully it'll become clear why i
didn't bother going any further
than 4 pi what would the next one be by
the way
be 6 pi right so you've got e to the i 6
pi
here but then when you divide by 3 you'd
get
along the end here you'd have e to the i
6 pi on 3 which is 2 pi i've already got
that solution
it's been covered ok i knew that because
this is a polynomial up here of degree
3. so i should expect exactly one
two three solutions this is really
important this idea it's so important it
gets
like other important things a name you
should write this down this is called
the fundamental theorem
you know they're not messing around when
they call something the fundamental
theorem right
the fundamental theorem of algebra
more formally stated it's that an nth
degree polynomial
will have exactly n solutions
if you count with multiplicity because
sometimes two solutions can sit
on the same spot but we still count them
as two solutions okay
so we can tie this up in a neat bow
right those things that you said before
about this shape i can get from here
idea number one i think i'm doing this
in different order for what you did but
i'm getting it out of here i think susie
was the one who mentioned
these moduli right they're all one it's
not immediately apparent
in rectangular form but it is apparent
in exponential form why is that
yeah where's the modulus it's this
coefficient out the front which in
all three cases is one right
so that's our first thing we should say
this is um
our properties of all
roots of unity number one
a nice neat way that we can say this is
that they're all on
the unit circle because that is the set
of points
that all have modulus one from the
origin right which is another reason why
it's called roots of unity
that's the first thing the second thing
is not just do we know something about
the moduli we know something about the
arguments
right i can't remember who mentioned it
but we've got these evenly spaced
arguments right
two pi and three two point three two pi
on three so
point two we would say they're equally
spaced on the circumference
uh from
the moduli is where i get point one from
the arguments is where i get point two
one last thing uh it was actually the
first thing i think that we said gi you
mentioned
uh we get this equilateral not
equilateral that's not the one i'm
looking for regular
we get this regular polygon a
regular polygon if you treat
the different roots of unity as the
vertices of a shape
this is cubits of unity so you got three
so you get an equilateral triangle
what shape would you get if we did the
fourth root of unity
you'd get a regular thing with four
sides a square and then a regular
pentagon and a regular
hexagon and so on now what's really
delightful is
property 1 and property 2 exactly give
you property 3 not just because it looks
like it
watch angle angle angle all the same
right sides also the same
so therefore my reasoning is these
outside
legs must be all we have a special name
for this
congruent right because you've got side
angle side
all three triangles identical does it
make sense
so you can see it doesn't just look like
it it comes directly out of the
properties